there are so many women with whom you
can sleep
and so few women with whom you can talk
i love to go to the zoo
but not on sunday
i don't like to see the people making
fun of the animals
when it should be the other way around
an intelligent man is sometimes forced
to be drunk to spend time with his fools
there is no lonelier man in death
than that man who has lived many years
with a good wife and then outlived her
if two people love each other there can
be no happy end to it
every man's life ends the same way
it is only the details of how he lived
and how he died
that distinguished one man from another
i like to listen
i have learned a great deal from
listening carefully
most people never listen
worry a little bit every day and in a
lifetime you will lose a couple of years
if something is wrong
fix it if you can
but train yourself not to worry
worry never fixes anything
fear of death increases in exact
proportion to increase in wealth
the world breaks every one end afterward
many are strong at the broken places
[Music]
there is nothing noble than being
superior to your fellow man
true nobility is being superior to your
former self
the most painful thing is losing
yourself in the process of loving
someone too much
and forgetting that you are special too
life isn't hard to manage when you've
nothing to lose
the human being is the only animal that
can laugh
even though he has least occasions for
that
now is no time to think of what you do
not have
think of what you can do with that there
is
the thing is to become a master in your
old age
to acquire the courage to do what
children did when they knew nothing
going to another country doesn't make
any difference
i've tried all that
you can't get away from yourself by
moving from one place to another
there's nothing to that
[Music]
no
that is the great fallacy
the wisdom of old men
they do not grow wise
they grow careful
courage is grace under pressure
so far about morals i only know that
what is moral is what you feel good
after
and what is immoral is what you feel bad
there is no friend as loyal as a book
the best way to find out if you can
trust somebody
is to trust them
women made such swell friends
awfully swell
in the first place you had to be in love
with a woman to have a basis of
friendship
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video subscribe